welcome to the climate show with me Tom
Heap I'm on my way to the global Summit
cop 27. I seem to have this bike lane to
myself
[Music]
and I'm in to this giant pop-up city of
do-gooders it's like a horizontal human
Hive of people with a purpose
35
000 of them over the Fortnight
politicians lobbyists business bosses
Charities all making deals
but this is actually the final weekend
of this meeting in fact it's already
overrun it should have ended yesterday
apparently they've been up all night
thrashing out the last elements of the
deal because all these cops are a
mixture of events happening around the
side business ngos other groups and then
the politicians themselves and what's
about to happen here is that the
European Union are going to give a
briefing on the very latest of what's
Happening excuse me in there in their
negotiations and so all the journalists
are crap gathered around waiting for the
latest Clues the latest hints of whether
it's going to be a bit of a failure or
whether someone's going to produce a big
climate saving rabbit out of the hat at
the end so let's go and see if what we
can find out and no we're not going to
be able to hear
the problem this is the European Union's
Chief negotiator Franz Timmerman's
talking tough threatening to walk away
if he doesn't get a deal at the front of
the scrum is Skye's climate reporter
Victoria Seabrook with a pointed
question on Europe's role thank you is
the EU
toxicity for paying for emissions
she has been here in Egypt for the whole
conference keeping across the highs and
lows of this latest effort to shove the
world onto a climate-friendly footing
with regular lives into Sky News so who
better to brief me on the state of play
we saw you in the thick of it earlier on
you're still working they're still
talking what are they all arguing about
it looks like it's coming down to two
key things
one of them is loss and damaged what
we've heard so much about at this
conference which is who pays when
climate disaster strikes looks like that
is very near the finish line now and
then the other thing that we think is
holding things up is cutting emissions
and limiting warming to 1.5 degrees I
often wonder are they all sitting in one
big meeting with 190 plus countries or
is it all divided up and do they have
separate speakers how does it work it
depends so sometimes they have big
meetings with almost everyone in one
room I was outside one earlier and when
they are meeting about the overarching
political document the cover decision
that comes out of this all of them more
or less try to get together except the
room isn't big enough so they have an
overflow room but then there's also
throughout the two weeks all kinds of
side meetings going on huddles different
ministers buddying up on different
things so it's arranged and it often
runs well into the night keeps you
covering a lot of distance and a lot of
time now you you mentioned earlier this
issue over 1.5 and also the things about
fossil fuels I gather that Saudi Arabia
has been a bit of a block on this that's
a fairly familiar story isn't it yes
exactly exactly and Russia as well so
last year at [ __ ] 26 in Glasgow
countries agreed to phase down coal and
that that was quite a win it wasn't
quite what some wanted but that's going
to be phase out we ended up in Phase
down at the last minute yeah that's
right
this year there's been a big push
funnily enough led by India who changed
that coal language last year there's
been a big push to try and broaden that
out to all fossil fuels the EU has got
behind that a few other countries
Saudi and Russia pushing back on that
but it it's bizarre because they're Big
Oil and Gas exporters themselves aren't
they yeah exactly and it's quite bizarre
because actually they've already agreed
to this the ipcc which is the United
Nations International climate science
body it already has language in about
phasing down fossil fuels that's already
been signed off by all governments right
and and that's from climate scientists
isn't it and I've been reading some
stuff around here and some climate
scientists who've been pretty vitriolic
about this facade of climate concern you
know the people with their eyes on the
molecules are worried yes when you
listen to The Climate scientists the
ones who really understand what is going
on you realize quite how bad things are
going to be some scientists don't come
here because they say it's a waste of
emissions it's detached from reality
wrangling over this language on the
other hand you've got a lot of
scientists here it's an incredible Forum
of all of these countries in one place
and they try and get leaders as they see
it to face the facts
[Applause]
the loss and damage in question are the
harms resulting from sea level rise
typhoons desertification
or the reverse floods punishing forces
of nature which cost lives and property
especially in the poorer world
should the rich long-term polluters pay
the Caribbean has seen worsening
hurricanes so I spoke to one of the
Region's Global ambassadors here
success for us looks like they they come
up with something uh something tangible
unless and damage I think that's really
really quite important I mean we've seen
so much land mass loss we're seeing so
much change in crop Cycles we're seeing
are lost biodiversity we're seeing Coral
bleaching there's so many things that
are happening and we're we're right
there looking at it and so we feel
extremely vulnerable when you add up
who's responsible it tends to be based
on the amount of carbon emitted yes I'm
just wondering and this might be a
British Focus because of course we
invented the Industrial Revolution but
is a ton of carbon emitted in 1800 when
we didn't know the damage yeah as guilty
as a ton of carbon emitted now when we
do know what it's doing yeah it is I
think so I think I think because that
carbon usually the irresponsibility is
today
yeah but you know my my position is less
about pointing fingers right as to okay
well I want you to do this although
there are things that I want others to
do but the reality is that carbon in the
atmosphere that Industrial Revolution
resulted in wealth in historical wealth
in generational wealth that we didn't
have access to that were now being
required to pay for so whether or not it
was something that
um you knew about at the time you
benefited from it and so and it's
causing damage what we know now is that
you know there are consequences to that
wealth but when someone's being punished
for something that's usually considered
just when they know it's something wrong
to do which we do much more today sure
and we didn't know 200 years ago sure
isn't that a reasonable
the reasonable distinction
but if if if someone was damaging your
country whether or not they understood
what they were doing at the time the
fact is you're incurring losses that you
can't afford to recoup so I think there
has to be an acknowledgment that listen
maybe maybe we frame it somehow maybe we
understand that that that it's a journey
that we're on in figuring out how to
solve this problem for example
um a hurricane uh Ian that just passed
of 67 billion dollars worth of damage
and that's a single incident we've had
20 million dollars worth of commitment
it's a huge gap and so and and so it's
boundless but at least an acknowledgment
that there is a problem and that we are
responsible without saying we are
responsible to cover all of it at least
that helps us to get started on solving
the problem
now you've been sending in your
questions and we promise to answer them
with a little help so here we go
Simon Layton via the Sky News app asks
how much will the UK reaching Net Zero
by 2050 actually change Global
temperature
[Applause]
well Simon the answer your question does
depend on how fast we decarbonize
because it's all about the amount of
carbon or other greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere but the estimate is it would
change Global temperature by between
point naught naught eight three of a
degree and point naught 1 6 of a degree
Centigrade so that's basically either
side of 100th of a degree now you might
say that's not very much but that's why
we're at a global Summit to bring people
along to make the change
Jules peel asks what area of crops will
be required to make the biofuel to power
a single transatlantic flight
great question Jules and some pretty big
figures now if you planted sugar beet
that's one of the more efficient at
making biofuel you'd need 25 hectares
that is about 1 000 tennis courts that's
just for that single flight
now that figure was given to us by the
aviation impact accelerator and they're
a group who also helped earlier in the
year when we made a program dedicated to
the challenges of reaching carbon
neutral flight you can see that program
by scanning the QR code on your screen
right now
[Applause]
Malcolm Moore's asks will delegates at
court accept that 1.5 degrees of warming
is an unrealistic Target and that it's
dead and that they should set a more
realistic one here well that's exactly
what they're talking about all around me
and here's one View
I don't think that all the parties at
cop will accept that 1.5 is dead in the
water
they'll want to keep it because even if
we're going to go over 1.5
countries and companies need to have
their 1.5 targets and the emissions
trajectory the emissions cuts to get
there even if not everyone and every
company in the world is doing that
because every little increment every 0.1
degrees C matters because climate
impacts will increase until we get
emissions right down to zero and we
stabilize Earth Earth climate
[Applause]
there may be deadlock at the top but
what about the thousands of deals that
are made by other people around here
join us after the break well we'll be
looking at breakthroughs in food and
farming energy and even climate-friendly
buildings
[Music]
welcome back well before the break we
were hearing how negotiators here are
struggling to agree a single tax to
conclude this meeting so given that are
the real breakthroughs on climate being
made here or down to developments
elsewhere
when we look actually is changing the
amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere it's things like you know
Engineers coming up with better cheaper
solar panels it's things like the war in
Ukraine putting up the cost of fossil
fuels those are the things that really
seem to change politicians Minds perhaps
not this so I don't think you're
advocating for war right the point I am
making is that it's big things away from
here which seem to be really making the
difference well of course because
engineers and you don't you don't you
don't negotiate the design of solar
panels right but what you do negotiate
is the headline targets so Net Zero in
Paris and then really really tightened
up just a 1.5 degrees in Glasgow why was
it tightened up because Paris asked the
scientists to come back and say What's
the difference between 1.5 and 2
differences 1.5 is bad two it's terrible
and then that ratchet mechanism which
Paris set in motion has started so that
the Paris goals start getting translated
into National goals but then what we
start to see happening is what I'm
responsible for working with is all
those non-state actors so you get cities
like London and Paris having low
emission zones and then you get our
manufacturer's saying you know what
we're going to go Net Zero by 2039 that
then emboldens
countries to be more so it's everything
everybody's feeding back off everybody
else so in effect what you're saying is
there's a sort of string or maybe
elastic that goes from what happens here
two companies or cities or inventors and
kind of pulls them in the right
direction yes and what we're seeing is
that that all converges towards what do
we got to do to get to Net Zero as
quickly as possible so one thing that's
been triggered by this process is very
clear sense of what the pathway to zero
is in every sector and then in Glasgow
we landed that as the Breakthrough
agenda so what do we have to do to get
to net zero steel
170 million tons of green steel plants
built by 2030. what have we got to do to
end the combustion engine 60 EV sales by
2030. what do we see here
in Sharma Shake 60 million tons of those
green steel plants are now in the
pipeline and we've had growing agreement
that we're going to end combustion
engine sales globally for cars in 2035
and trucks in 2040. and I met someone
from the building sector who was quite
excited about what's happened there tell
me yeah so again built environment huge
40 of emissions come from buildings in
building them and operating them and now
we've included the the Breakthrough on
buildings in this breakthrough agenda
with Morocco and France leading on that
and then the world Green Building
Council and many many businesses all
getting behind those same short-term
goals you know reducing admissions
massively by 20 zero carbon operations
and at least 40 reduction in the in the
material content of the carbon yeah so
it really will change the way buildings
are built and operated to make them more
climate friendly what happened here what
happened here as a as a forcing
mechanism and a convening point and it
will have to be translated then it's a
company investment plans company r d
plans city building regulations
government procurement regulations so
you can't solve the problem here but you
can send the signals by convening around
the headline Target which then get
implemented everywhere else are cops a
lot of talk that provides a critical
foundation for action or are they a mask
for inaction
that's very complicated process trying
to get 190 plus countries to agree on
anything so there's often an element of
lowest common denominator around what's
affected their single-party veto so I
think the accusation of a mask for
inaction
um
sometimes valid when people have
deliberately trying to slow things down
but by firing away what they are is is a
creation of a framework for Action which
then requires other processes to fill in
but that then feeds back right because
the more you see momentum from The Real
World the more emboldened negotiators
um to do their job and set higher and
faster targets and that's what we're
seeing here it's a huge risk it's a huge
mistake to think that the only measure
of success is The Negotiator text it's
also a huge mistake to dismiss the
negotiations as not being relevant
anymore
the punishing effects of climate change
of course don't stop during cop and
nowhere more so than Africa in Nigeria
recently they've been devastating floods
killing over 600 people forcing more
than half a million off their land and
threatening the food supply for Millions
our Africa correspondent usra El bagair
reports from the state of Benway
floods have come and gone
and the Waters of the river benue have
finally receded
the natural piece of life here seems to
have been restored but has it
benue state is the food basket of
Nigeria Africa's most populous country
and though the deadly flooding has
passed the deeper damage will be felt in
the months ahead
not here men again
they are rest finished
Nigerian households rely heavily on rice
and demand has outstripped Supply in
recent years
and now flooding has hampered production
even more so we are affected by the
flood
water came
Bridget has been processing rice since
2015.
so I said I was producing a ton and
slightly above a ton of rice per day
and the coming of the flood so affected
us uh even one to two bags we cannot
even Mill a day now as it is
a majority of Nigeria states have been
impacted by unprecedented flooding that
destroyed houses and left more than a
million homeless it's this damage to a
developing economy that is at the heart
of the climate Justice debate and at
this year's climate conference activists
are demanding Western Nations pay their
ecological debt
look at the number of people that have
died already you want to wait until
everyone in Africa is dead
this is the time for climate Justice and
climate Justice is human rights look at
the the farmers
is not easy all your income will go
within one day
we met farmers who have lost everything
just a few of thousands who have seen
their farmlands washed away
all around here are crops that have been
damaged by torrential rains that left
this land flooded for around a month and
even though the flood waters have
receded these are rice crops that are
unharvestable in a country that relies
on the crop to feed its population
is almost a hundred percent loss because
there will be no Harvest so there's
nothing usable there is nothing usable
here this gun is gone
the most fertile land in the country now
water locked
the rice could not stand
the pressure of the water
and at the end of the day we understand
that the whole thing has some are dry so
much rotten and everything has gone look
at it
so almost every home is rice
so but you can see thousands of hectares
of rice are washed away
so it is it's a signal that we
experience hunger next year
it's not just Farmers here assessing the
damage
families rifle through the rot for
anything they can Mill and eat at home
and as world leaders discuss climate
change hunger tightens its grip
Sky News benue state
[Applause]
the whole point of these meetings is to
lessen the chance of disasters like that
happening in the future so as this cop
winds down I'm groping from my own final
communique let's have a look at some of
the things I've witnessed
hope and purpose from so many especially
but not only younger delegates climate
change is the single biggest threat to
humanity we are here to represent the
voices of young people it's always been
about survival of the planet not just
for listening we come here to be here
that's why I'm here
this year for the first time there was a
youth and children's Pavilion
[Music]
but many weren't in step with the
dominant Melody
have my license
[Applause]
that discontent was shared at the top
table we want a good decision
but it's better to have no decision than
a bad decision
but measured by weight of numbers this
is where much of the action is huge
promotions from many countries pushing
their green credentials Sometimes using
artworks with slightly opaque
environmental links
it's easy to be cynical about this my
exhibit is bigger than yours
grandstanding but at least climate
change is on thousands of lips
so now they're packing up
a bit of a feeling that the party's over
what has been achieved
sepi gulzari Monroe has been closing
deals
now she's closing the shop
it's all packing up here uh hi Tom you
guys have been on go and not only on the
big meetings with industry
well yeah it looks like last orders the
wind energy bar here and how's it gone
for you yep we've we've actually had a
really a great couple of weeks here
talking with a broad range of
governments that you know have been
seeking out the the wind and solar
Industries because they're really
connecting the dots on how Renewables
can help solve the multiple crises that
they're seeing in their countries and
then them seeking it out is that a bit
of a change in the past you were selling
to them and now they're buying from you
yeah absolutely I think you know there's
really been a step change this year with
the skyrocketing gas prices and so
really many countries see it in their
economic uh self-interest to really go
go big on Renewables can you point to an
actual deal made him yes sure you know
we've we've seen and the southern Africa
clean energy pool come together to
deploy 18 billion dollars in order to
get 8.2 gigawatts of Renewables and just
as we're getting some other shots
oh no let me just turn the lights out
they have just turned the lights out on
the page literally as we've been filming
we can do some other shots and they've
killed the lights in this Pavilion does
show that it's coming to an end oh well
I guess that's it then absolutely thank
you for dropping by
and some observers spy crumbs of comfort
for food and farming too making the trip
worthwhile are you a firm believer that
it's worth your presence your flight and
the 30 000 others that are here in terms
of actually helping the climate yeah
absolutely well I mean we did some
analysis the emissions from a copper
about 70 000 times smaller than Global
emissions every year so the impact is
really small people who say that it's
not worth all the flights really if you
look at the numbers actually the
difference that a cop makes to Global
emissions is massive compared to the
small amount of emissions caused by
having one but more generally what a cop
is about is not just the texts and the
negotiations that come out of it it is
about creating that momentum so for
example again we've seen the doubling of
Finance for agricultural technology that
will help cut emissions from four to
eight billion at this cop and we've seen
the un's food agency say it's going to
produce the first ever plan on how the
food system can contribute to keeping
temperature rises to just 1.5 degrees
in the end the success of this cop
shouldn't really be measured on the
quality of words but rather the quantity
of greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
and for an answer on that we'll have to
wait
[Music]